[Music]
last wednesday was national corvette day
to celebrate i met up with the crew from
spring mountain racing
to put the 2021 corvette c8 to the test
[Music]
the corvette has been part of the fabric
of america for over 65 years and today
we're getting up close and personal with
a c8
this is shawn with chevrolet and sean
today i'm going to do a hot lap in the
c8 and it's not called a hot lap because
it's 115 degrees outside
what is a hot lap it is hot for sure but
what we're trying to show here is really
the riding handling capabilities of this
supercar
we're going to teach you how to be a
better driver on the track and on the
street on a day-to-day basis all right
before we get on the track let's do a
let's still walk through and kind of
introduce me to the corvette c8
this is an entirely new design eighth
generation corvette
mid engine car engine has never been in
the middle of the car it's always been
in the front
this has made the cockpit of the car
move forward just like a jet fighter
so you get better sight better control
better balance
great aerodynamics you can see some of
the jet fighter themes as you build the
car right here
how many horsepower in this z51 package
is 495 horse
0 to 60 in 2.9 seconds all right top
speed of about 180
i do feel like i'm sitting in a fighter
jet right now this is a really cool
setup
yeah as you can see the steering wheel
is set up for you know performance and
track
you've got your eight speed automatic
transmission we also have the paddle
shifts
right here okay right here here's your
actual gear right here so it's just push
button gear and then this is your driver
mode
weather tour sport or track so that
gives you four different modes there's
no shifter here so this is where i can
kind of rest my hand if i'm used to
holding a shifter in my car because
everything is done
right here it's that simple so if you
want to if you want to pretend you're in
a manual for example
push the manual button and there's your
paddles weather mode and you know you
get eco on this you can get 30 miles a
gallon on the freeway on this thing
traveling if you're in eco mode you put
it on the track it puts the exhaust
into play you've got all your safety
systems from stability control magnetic
ride control
everything now this is this paddle of
buttons right here what do we got here
yeah these are all your controls that
you're used to seeing on the dashboard
so the top half of it is the driver air
conditioning seat
auto and then the bottom part is for the
passenger and so
there's something here now these three
buttons here i think are just
genius because we have the front camera
i press that correct you can see that as
you're pulling up so if you're coming up
to a wall it will help guide you
to where to stop not only that you hit
the other button and the car has a two
inch lift so if you're coming in a
driveway for example that has a slight
increase the scraper
you can raise the front end once you do
it once it'll program itself
up to a thousand different gps locations
so next time you come to your home
it will automatically as you come up to
it it will rise so you do it you don't
have to do it every single time
every single sports car should have that
feature so many times i'm pulling in
somewhere
scrape scrape scrape or i'm pulling in a
parking lot i don't realize how close
the curb stop is
and hear the crunch this is a lifesaver
on the vehicle
absolutely absolutely all right how do
you take me on the hot lap no ricky's
going
rick bobby rick malone we call him ricky
bobby bobby's going to take me on my hot
lap but get ricky bobby over here let's
do this thing all right buddy rick
malone chief driver instructor and
driving school director for the ron
fellow performance driving school
and we're about to give jc a hot lap
right now all right you ready
let's do it here we go this is the
warm-up
on the brake i'm
[Music]
we're just riding here back into it this
is very smooth actually
extremely it's very smooth yeah
and we're gonna go through it again now
we got some heat in our tires and now
we're warmed up ready to go again
yeah now we're gonna do what we call
launch control launch control
this is launch control give me one
second oh i need to compose myself all
right
launch control what does that mean okay
the computer's gonna control the wheel
spin
i'm gonna put the brake pretty hard i'm
gonna floor the throttle uh-huh
absolutely really cool but here's the
thing these seats though i'm not sliding
around on this thing oh you're just
nice and comfortable look at this
amazing isn't it we put a 94.1
we sure can't keep your hands on the
wheel
[Music]
wow holy smokes and if you noticed
when you asked me to put the radio on it
didn't lose my composure because i
already had the information on the track
yeah i was about to turn the radio on
for you but it was already set to 94.1 i
was just testing ricky it's already set
what'd you think of your ride rick thank
you so much incredible
amazing car that's that's what you call
it hot lap everybody
it is hot outside and it's hot on the
lap thank you rick i appreciate it
i might do it again that was an awesome
day you can experience the power of the
corvette at spring mountain racing
in pahrump las vegas now